all right take a seat pour a cocktail
we're about to blow your mind for more
than 30 years Nancy Pelosi as you well
know is represented the single most
liberal congressional district in
America and she's always seemed
perfectly suited for the job named the
issue no matter what it is from abortion
to climate change to affirmative action
and Nancy Pelosi has the party approved
doctrinaire left position on that issue
she's a walking liberal stereotype or so
we thought in fact it was all a pose it
was a sham identity designed to cloak a
darker reality beneath you thought Nancy
Pelosi was a guilty white liberal who
regularly sends money to the annual NPR
pledge drive didn't you knew who in fact
Pelosi is a committed racist a hardening
to bigot she'd be running the lady's
clan axillary if they had one in San
Francisco kind of shocking actually
how do we know this simple watch the way
Nancy Pelosi dismisses fellow
congresswoman Alexandria Acacio Cortez
she likes to minimize the conflicts
within her caucus between the moderates
and the progressives you have these
wings AOC and her group on one side side
side people it's like five people
actually it's four people but of course
a racist would get the number wrong plus
he was referring to congresswoman Acacio
Cortes Yohan Omar Rasheeda Talib and
Ayanna pressi or as Pelosi doubtless
thinks of them the four morons of the
apocalypse closely does not like them
she's made that clear and Acacio Cortes
having thought about it a lot think she
knows why in a recent interview with The
Washington Post Acacio Cortes accused
Pelosi of quote singling out newly
elected women of color get it yeah press
to explain herself later Acacio Cortes
noted that Pelosi has attacked these
women of color despite quote knowing the
amount of death threats that we get I
think it's just worth asking why yeah
okay let's rhetorical question obviously
she knows why why else would you imperil
someone's safety well because you wish
them harm because you're a crazed bigot
according to Alexandria Acacio Cortes
that
she was running the Democratic Party
right now quick someone alert out
Sharpton in the Civil Rights Division at
DOJ we've got a racist third in line to
the presidency maybe we're being too
literal about this what are the odds in
real life that Acacio Cortes actually
believes that Nancy Pelosi is a racist
or that Joe Biden is a racist or for
that matter that Donald Trump is a
racist what a chance that she really
thinks that probably about zero the
first thing to know about the cries of
racism you hear incessantly from the
left they are totally insincere no one's
saying it actually believes it the point
isn't to get rid of racism the point is
to seize power and it works denouncing
someone as racist is a kind of
rhetorical stun grenade for a moment the
accused just stands there off-balance
and looking bewildered that's when you
scoop up the loot and run grievance
politics is a kind of smash and grab
operation and it's highly effective it's
no surprise that the left now justifies
its entire political program in the name
of fighting bigotry America has been
accused of racism therefore we must I
don't know picket give up our guns empty
our prisons legalize drugs give up the
First Amendment pay for someone else's
abortion tear down our borders by the
way we're not allowed to ask about
citizenship on our census form because
racism see how it works yeah the
question is how did Nancy Pelosi fall
for this she's been working this game so
long herself you think she would have
seen it coming but apparently she didn't
Heather McDonald D is the author of the
diversity delusion and she joins us
tonight Heather nice to see you tonight
are you surprised having followed this
whole line of argument for so many years
and so closely are you surprised that
Pelosi and Biden for that matter of both
being denounced as racist right now
no it's hilarious Tucker I mean let's
take a moment to just savor this moment
well thank you turns on itself yeah the
left turns on itself wielding the exact
weapons that it wields against everybody
else and accuses itself of racism it's
preposterous
but it's also a serious matter I
disagree slightly with you to say that
people don't believe this I think what
we're witnessing is the most dangerous
import from the Academy into the real
world students are taught from the
moment they arrived on campus two things
and two things only
reliably which is that the most
important thing about themselves is
their group identity defined reductively
by gonads and melanin and that racism
sexism based on those characteristics
are the defining features of American
society
taught to believe that when they face
any kind of disagreement they
reflexively accuse their ideological
opponent of bigotry and hate and that's
works wonderfully on a college campus
you accuse a president of racism
he immediately crumples and orders
another million dollars in diversity
bureaucracy you accuse a corporation of
racism and it folds as we saw with Nike
and the preposterous claim that the
Betsy Ross flag is racist
it works with politicians with Biden
repudiating his justified support for
the 94 federal crime bill that saved
thousands of minority lives the question
is is it going to work on the rest of us
and if it does Tucker civil society is
over because this is a totalitarian
power play it is an attempt to shut down
any kind of dialectical search for truth
and to occupy the sole allowable
ideological ground and that's a recipe
for a society to halt dead in its tracks
and go in reverse because it's not
really an argument I mean no one's
making the case and by the way this
eliminates the need to make the case you
don't actually have to convince anybody
of anything if you're doing it to fight
racism it's a moral imperative and
everyone else can just shut up and obey
you know there's been political
disagreements long before identity
politics people disagree that is what
America is about that we have the right
we have the freedom to debate our
opinions the alternative to debate is
violence it is an act of narcissism to
think that everything is about yourself
to immediately say well it must be
because of my gender and race that I'm
being disagreed with and you must be a
bigot to disagree with me no that is not
the case these are issues that deserve
to be thrashed out in the public forum
and again if they are not we are
approaching a totalitarian state very
quickly and so this is a much longer
conversation but in the short time 30
seconds a we have would you recommend
what course of action for normal people
ignore these slurs for the kind of
cynical politics that they are how
should your average person fight back
against this totalitarianism well the
average person has to simply reject the
racism charge all of us have to start
working on alternative explanations for
our reality
racism is no longer the predominant
characteristic of America if it ever was
it was a part of it it was never the
defining feature but it certainly is not
this still remains a land of opportunity
the alternative explanation is that
there are profound behavioral
differences choices that individuals
make that determine social outcomes we
have to fight back against this
narrative Tucker because if they win we
lose our civilization we lose
meritocracy and we lose freedom